it all depends on what level you you
place it i think there's continues there
still is a great sharing of values
between europe and the u.s. so the
Western world is still driven by by the
same the same basic values and and that
I think they will continue whether
there's there are bumps on the road
there will always be bumps on the road
when when one of the members is is
taking an action that does not have
consensus and obviously that's a bump on
the road but fundamentally I don't see
there have been many occasions where the
transatlantic eight lines could have
collapsed and it has not so I don't see
I don't see that's happening at all
well it's always a question of
understanding the world as it is and you
know being global citizens I mean you
know the people have a hard time dealing
with the fact that they are part of a
nation with a part of the world as well
and that's what I call / 0 volts it is
it so the question is can you be a
global citizen and still a country
citizen and whether you know there's a
conflict between those two there can be
at times I you know hopefully
progressively this will change but this
is a major dilemma because if we go
towards a more of a global governance
model the role of nations will diminish
as we see today in the European Union
for example which progressively
authority and autonomy is lost and
transferred to a to a larger larger
group of states which I think prefigures
the World of Tomorrow I think at some
point we'll have a global government I
won't see it but maybe you will but you
know there are some countries that are
so nationalistic that they have a very
hard time to deal with that that in the
end I think this trend is inevitable
that rice broken by country I think
there's always been an admiration from
the mental admiration for the history of
the United States what it has
accomplished in you know 200-plus years
and the but there's also you know some
maybe some Envy some jealousy the
overpowering media culture that is you
know so powerful around the world
sometimes irritates people but you know
the end and they are and then they are
some differences and certainly the Iraq
war was a major point of contention even
with either Europe was obviously against
it and but see even that didn't rupture
Lee from the mental transatlantic
Alliance Hurley a little bit but it's
always get getting repaired I think that
there's this admiration and there is
some some irritation about when there's
too much imperialism or aggressiveness
on the part of the u.s. in in some
instances so whether its military or
cultural they're always provokes some
some responses but you know overall I
think the the admiration still in might
if you draw a bottom line I think it's
still positive because the values the US
have the Democratic environment at the
US plays into the role they play on on
technology and on advancing new concepts
is is is really a powerful powerful
thing that's that's highly recognized
Oh